[Music]
[Applause]
Steve Tasker the Buffalo Bill great and
now works for the Buffalo Bills one
bills live which airs weekdays from 1 to
3 Eastern and uh also wgr sports radio
550 uh I know it's short notice joining
us Steve so thank you how was it getting
to the stadium this
morning this morning it was uh pretty
problem free not not a big issue I we've
got I'm about 12 or 13 minutes from the
stadium we got about 18 to 22 over the
weekend and uh you know driveway's
plowed roads are clear it's all it's all
going to be fine today um if you get
them a chance if you get them a chance
uh you know the the snow maral people
here in Western New York are pretty on
it they know what they're doing but it
does take some time and this this
snowstorm couldn't have hit at a worst
moment okay the role that weather will
play today this afternoon for this game
is what just a just a cold weather game
um it's sunny here now it's bright and
sunny and clear um which is kind of the
way it works out here right so uh I
think it's going to be a normal uh Sunny
clear cold game I don't know what the
surface of the field is going to be
because it did get a lot of snow uh
they'll try and clear at which they will
but uh and it'll stay clear don't know
if it's frozen solid though that's going
to be an issue uh we'll have to wait and
see what the how the field progresses
during the day but for the most part
running around playing these guys will
be fine as far as game plans does do the
conditions or playing a day later change
the philosophy with Buffalo offensive
game plan and and the Steelers offensive
game plan I don't think so I think it
goes back to more normal if they played
they tried to go yesterday it would have
been a farce um neither team would have
been able to do anything it was just
horrible out um it would have been un
unbelievably bad so that uh G today
having the game today really comes down
to which team can have a a late wrench
thrown into their routine and be okay
with it uh certainly I think it'll be
much easier for the bills at home to
hang in there another day rather than
have the Steelers I mean I I as a player
Dan you know you get into a routine in
the season you're ready to go you got
your your pregame you're pre-travel you
get to you go to the restaurant you get
your food you go to the plane you get on
the plane you sit with your boys you
know you're all of that now all that got
put on hold you know I mean it's like
all of a sudden it's not there so these
guys got like wow I now we've got all
these guests in town now I gotta kind of
stay another 24 hours when I should be
playing now we're not playing now I gota
wait to go to the hotel it's going to be
a
big distraction in the last hours
leading up to this game because of this
24-hour delay and I think it you know
how it is some of the guys are going to
handle it fine it's not going to be a
deal some of them it might be better for
them others it's going to be
catastrophic it's going to be a
distraction they're gonna show up all
hairy they got a problem you know the
wife the kids the mom and dad's in town
you know you got all the stuff going on
trying to get your family to the game
and uh some guys will handle it well and
some won't and I think that's the thing
that is going to be interesting to see
and that's really too one of the
unpredictable things about this storm
hitting and I also wonder about this
that the bills maybe they don't need to
be reminded but they're reminded they're
10-point favorites against the Steelers
coming in without TJ watt but looking
what happened to the Cowboys yesterday
uh some of the surprises here the Browns
losing against the Texans it's almost
like they were able to see this watch
this and just remind themselves that do
not take Pittsburgh for granted yeah and
I think I think it's going to be really
interesting to see what the game plan is
because if you're if you're a heavy
favorite in the this is a I've said it
before this has been a team that's been
good enough to go to and win the Super
Bowl for about four or five years now
but they haven't played well on the last
game of the season you got to play well
on that day um you can be the better
team but it doesn't matter if you don't
play well um some of that pressure I
think comes along with this Bills team
after what happened last year certainly
with the Demar Hamlin and all the things
and the two storms that they had to
suffer through and all the stuff they
went through last year they were done at
the end of last year this year is's not
really that many excuses they need to
play well and there if they feel that
kind of pressure it could it could cause
them to come out flat and get off to a
slow start like like M like Miami did
like the Dallas Cowboys did so it'll be
interesting to see how they do now
certainly if they handle this delay well
and come out and play their game and
they come out and aggressive and you see
Josh Allen throwing it around a little
bit early yeah there's no stopping this
team this Bills team is really good now
they'll nobody's going to I don't care
who it is nobody's going to beat these
guys like the Cincinnati Bengals did
last year by double digits they don't
lose games by double
digits uh they win them like that
sometimes but this is a team that goes
into one score games a lot so um they're
GNA take a punch they can take a punch
if uh if this Pittsburgh team starts to
swing at him it always comes down to
Josh Allen is the reason why they're
going to win and Josh challenge factors
in when they lose Steve I mean it just
feels like that that's the reality it
sounds harsh but that's that's the
feeling I get do you think that that's
the case for this team this year yeah I
don't know I think the only reason that
people kind of point to Josh being the
reason they lose he he puts the ball at
risk and you look at the top
quarterbacks in the in the NFL they're
all in the playoffs and they all turn it
over a bunch um now they'll go through
stretches where they won't like like
Jordan love has gone through a stretch
where now he's not turning it over and
that's a huge boost but I think if
you're going to play well and play well
offensively in the NFL you're going to
put the ball at risk you got to have a
quarterback that's going to sling it
Josh has never been shy about doing that
and like I said even if he turns it over
three times I mean this team was minus
three in the turnover Department in a
game and won it um they don't care uh
they know they can score points they
know Josh is going to keep him on the
field when he needs to he's going to run
it when he needs to he is and I think
this is what this is what the point in
history we're at Dan if you got a great
quarterback he isn't great unless he can
take the perfect defensive call for
their team and turn it into a touchdown
for your team Josh does it Lamar does it
momes does it it's a short list Josh is
at the top of it have fun today great to
talk to you as always Steve thanks for
joining us I'm the legend of the game I
get I get to rev the crowd up before the
game so it'll be fun awesome awesome
thank you thank you Steve
Steve Tasker former bills all proo CBS
sports analyst